[Music]
yo what's up this big boy aka daddy fat
sacks on this side and this is sleepy
brown aka the one and together we are
the big sleepover and right now we're
gonna run through some of our most
iconic jams it's some of our most iconic
man come on man take you on the journey
with us man yeah yeah let's ride out
ride out rider
[Music]
when we started doing the criminal we
were at doppler another studio and then
just bringing in
plethoras musicians from percussionists
to bass players and guitar players and
horn players and you know you got songs
like spodiote yeah and just really it
was a blank canvas and you can just do
whatever you want to do that's one thing
when you use uh live instruments you're
not just locked into one group
the night has gone by
is it true that you were sued by the
estate of rosa parks for that song
uh yes but it was crazy we were in her
hometown or something and this was after
she had passed and we have some of her
family members came up to where we were
at and they were like you know that's
not our family that's these uh the
people that are behind her that are
going after y'all we know y'all didn't
mean any harm behind the song the song
was to enlighten and uplift and you know
but [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's always about yeah
the story behind players ball is
basically l.a came to us and said yo we
got a christmas album and uh we need one
more record so can you get the boys to
do one for outcast and we were like huh
okay so we went we went so big and drake
rico told me andre yo we gonna do this
christmas record they were already
thinking oh they're trying to destroy it
i'm trying to [ __ ] our crib
so the original title of the song was
socks and drawers because that's all you
got yeah wow you got a certain damn i
forgot about that you got a certain age
like when you started like 11 you
started getting socks and drawers you're
not getting toys though so that was the
first the title of the title was socks
and drawers
first title with socks and draws what
ended up happening was the beat
that became players ball ray was
actually doing it for uh left eyes group
jenna said quoi and rico heard it and
were like man you out your goddamn mind
we're not giving that a deal so
so me rico and rey are standing there
and rico just started saying man
the scene was packed because what we
wanted to do was use this sample but we
didn't use it because the face wasn't
playing it so
basically rico kind of just made up his
own and which gave me the idea to do the
hook
[Music]
and actually we had to pick between the
two beats because it was a tlc sleigh
ride right and it was and it was the
players ball beat and we was like man we
was like we want that one that's right
they gave the first deal
that one we picked right beater here we
are today
[Music]
he was like man we gonna make no
christmas song man just talk about how
we kicking on christmas at the dinners
man like we're saying we do this the
same day every day because we was all
grown already right and it was like okay
this is what we do in christmas we'll go
get some drink we might get a plate and
just talk about you know our experiences
like they know chimneys in the ghetto
you know we're gonna be hanging on socks
on those chimneys well i got chimneys
not on
[Music]
is a real a real true south anthem you
got yeah a track produced by three six
mafia yes sir with outcast and ugk on
there you can't get no more dirty south
you can't get no more dare to shout out
to pimp c man yeah yeah r.i.p pimp
ass paul mccartney the lawyers couldn't
stop this slaughter of them
you know just had the heavyweights going
to bet and everybody knocking that [ __ ]
over the fence like everybody's gonna
come up the back pie is gone pie is gone
man
i remember before pimp pass he called me
about that wreck he said man we're gonna
win the wars with this one sleeping
you're gonna win the war this is
something never happened mate you got
triple six u-g-k-a outcasts no he said
okay yeah okay
he's like man come on and i knew by his
excitement it was going to be a really
big record
[Music]
i was over at
our studio of organized noise over at
the house played on the keys at the uh
studio sung and kind of for reek
the uh the little melody and enrique uh
basically came up with the words the
next day i walked in rico had the words
enrico told me like when he got up that
morning he was in the shower he just
kind of started saying it ain't nobody
though has been you know saying came to
him right there which was cool man it
just came together like that you know it
was big heard it big got right on it he
loved it teddy pendergrass cooler than
freddie jackson sipping a milkshake and
a snow storm that's what the warm in the
darkroom at the au all right first i
start with uh the long legal notepad the
yellow one i need a super long one
because sometimes i might scratch lines
out or whatever right on the spot you
know i put a lot of thought into it
sometimes it might take a day sometimes
it might take months to do a verse you
know what i'm saying it just depends on
how i'm feeling freestyling is you know
that's something that we do and just
just for play play but you know just got
to be potent when you
sipping the milkshake in the snowstorm
yeah
you got to really think about that
for sure
[Music]
it was a reference to the mississippi
river you know what i'm saying i will
flow yeah in my quick letter quickly
letter i humpback hunk back i the
mississippi river i was flowing like the
mississippi you feel me a lot of [ __ ] go
over people's heads sometimes so it'll
take time for you to kind of dial in but
yeah fat sax is a very complex character
man yeah well yeah that's that's what it
was yeah definitely
yeah
buying like mpc drum machines
and sb 1200 drum machines had little
boss 808 machines and
keyboards and whatnot and we just
started tinkering around we both set up
little home pre-production studios
and it just all came from being you know
students under organized noise just kind
of watching them
and
they
i guess they trusted us in our
production we started you know making
beats and we come playing from there
like oh man that's funky man you know
what i'm saying and from there just
to the moon
[Music]
i can remember like at aliens the actual
title track but before we put the bass
line on there we had a [ __ ]
they're playing the tuba
but it was just moving too slow so that
we had to go back and put the bass on
there but it was trying different things
like you said to layer it and so you can
really
really really really put the groove
right in their face alien identity came
from just being outsiders being an
outcast you know what i'm saying whether
you're extraterrestrial or illegal alien
you know what i'm saying
you just ain't accepted yeah so you know
otherworldly you know you think in
another dimension and outside the box we
just don't conform to what's going on in
this particular space and time
[Music]
it's the place where all the funky
things come from the alternate bizarro
universe drake's just kept saying i
think i can i think i can and we just
come up with these words man the drake
came over like stank only that's like
boom yeah that's where we're from are we
going to be the atl and we're from
stankoni
believe it i love your mom and
everything see i ain't the only one who
lay down if you want to rip you up start
a custody
we just feed off each other like of each
other's energy like it's whoever catch
the vibe first and then from there is
you know uh all about the individual
perspective after that you know so we
just kind of bounce off each other like
and it just it works
beautifully i mean it's just how you
build what you really know about the
dirty
it was right after we put out something
playlisted and goody mom was working on
soul food yeah so we were out doing
promo runs and things like that and we
come back to the dungeon and he'll get
him off doing cell therapy and them just
covering their own path and it was like
hey we got this wreck for you to get on
man i was like what and it was a big
gift that you know asked me to be on the
record and
it was jamming it's definitely the
anthem not the camp like i said gave the
it made the south dirty it made the
dirty south this red clay known across
the world and i mean from there it was
just sky's the limit
dirty soft was basically uh
uh artist cool breeze was his his uh
idea um to come up with that name dirty
south is really yeah that that
definitely represents atlanta that name
gave uh self identity yes it gave us
ideally absolutely so shout out to cool
breeze for that man credit card who yeah
who's cut that camp yes sir
[Music]
i had beat for years and i had a cookout
at my house yeah and we were in the boom
boom room and i played it
and then brown was like wait a minute
and then he started like huh i'm like
okay cool like we gonna work on this man
next and we brought it in in the studio
man and i promise you this man got in
there and just went crazy and i was like
wow that's like this going to be one of
the ones so
i had to be real meticulous with my pen
after that because i knew
it was the jam jam
i've always been kind of known as like
the silent member or the third member
outcast which has always been a blessing
and it started with so far so clean
so by the time we got to the way you
moved that was the record that really
put me out you know as far as big
letting everybody see who i was and
doing verses and all that stuff
because you know i remember when you
know like really la wanted us to do it
you know what i'm saying but you know
little bro stuck up for me it's like no
don't keep sleeping on it which i really
appreciate him for doing it because it
really took it took me to another level
as far as finally one to one team to be
known as the artist i knew it was a
great record when i first heard the hook
i knew it was gonna be a great record i
didn't know how big it was gonna be
though you know i didn't know that when
it came out you know on the charts it'll
be like hey y'all one week and number
one the way you're moving number two the
next day would be the way you the way
you're moving number one and hey y'all
number two was battling with each other
which was really incredible and i just
you know man it was such a blessing to
have a record like that man
such a blessing
[Music]
i remember drake calling me and uh
wanted me to come to
boston at the time
which was him stacking on him the band
that he was using was a band that i was
using called sleepy's thing my hand did
an album called snippy's theme and it
was kinda like most of the same players
and when i came to the studio and i
heard that groove like wow this is
different and crazy
so i'm like what you want me to do on it
he was like man just kind of sing about
you know what's going on in your day
that day like what what's sleepy doing
when he waking up and what's going on it
just became a vibe man just you know
spoiled just became one of those records
that
i don't know bro it's just it's organic
man it's so organic that's what it is
when i first met my expo that older
dopalicious angel i couldn't remember
that damn thing like yesterday when it's
free-flowing and you have freedom in the
groove you can do whatever you want to
do and we would like to call our
performances on that record was called
not spoken word but smoking word
nice
i was over there at drive
and they was sucking and jiving and i
called l.a and ellie was like come on
come on home i had uh
for your sorrows
and then i had shutterbug that was
produced by scott storch and when i let
l.a hear
shutterbug he was like holy [ __ ] he flew
me to new york we had a listening party
and then it was boom we was back on
it playable some choose to play it's
safe but check the resume it's risky
business in the aaa and i've been
witness to this history ever since the
10th grade we went from rock and race to
tempe i went to miami
scott stewart's house he
had some of the loudest speakers i've
ever heard i think that's the loudest i
ever heard music played in my life he
almost blew my eardrums like went down
there and was just checking out some
beats and then we went in this little
studio and man he turned this song up so
loud man i was like damn that's it and
we stood out side by the boat we had the
boat outside it was like hey man we need
to work on it so i brought it back to
atlanta
and began writing to it and then sent it
back and forth to him he was like holy
[ __ ] we did it
[Music]
definitely that was uh from my uncle he
was just like your pimp title well
you're sir you're really you're nighting
rhyming armor
left foot you know what i'm saying so he
just took the sword and put it over my
shoulder like this i got down on one
knee and then he my coordination was in
savannah georgia like right by the
alligator pit in in uh the barbecue
joint and so lucy's left foot was born
on a stormy summer night
yeah
straight pimping man
man he's cool as hell man like we
recorded right here in this studio again
stank only the place where all funky
things come from i just called him he's
like man i got this song i want you to
get on with me so he pulled up
like a couple of hours later in the
yellow lamborghini you can't call me big
dog big dog
dog what you we do big dog
and it might have took him like 10 or 15
minutes man he killed it we knew it was
the jam cup master swift produced it and
then
maybe two or three weeks later went to
jail
like goddamn so i had to shoot a video
for it because i believed in the record
and i just was showing like pictures and
footage of them it looked like a goddamn
memorial
video almost
[Music]
you know do it until in the show to this
day live and [ __ ] and then we actually
performed at v103 car and bike show and
rock the [ __ ] out that [ __ ] if it's all
right
i wanna kick it with you all night
all night i'm gonna tell you where it
came from it came from l.a reed i was
here and i was working and he was like
hey
i got this song
i know you'll just do something else
with it and he sent it to me i was like
okay
that's that's that's that's dope so uh
it was a lunch money lewis wrote the
hook and dr luke produced it and i just
wrote all the rhymes in the bridge and
put the flavor on there and it turned
out to be a smiz ass man another gold if
not platinum plaque 90s 2000s 2010s i
got plaques in three different decades
that [ __ ] crazy do not look classy [ __ ]
don't act so sassy killer mike brought
me that record he was like bro i got
something special for you
and he was like we got to do it together
so it got to be me and you gave me the
record i was like this [ __ ] hard as [ __ ]
man so right in this room right here we
went in we just started writing
with three
[ __ ]
there's another whole version of that
song with different verses on it because
we did some verses then we're like
we'll let's let's do it another kind of
way so i got a demo version of my phone
i was like wow that [ __ ] was dope as
hell too
so just the chemistry of just you know
um
jedi rap [ __ ] trading bars with killer
mic i mean keeping each other sharp
but we were done before any
uh pandemic happened like that was done
and it came done and we were just about
to drop it and then [ __ ] they dropped
they got down to colby's on us so he was
like hold on until we were able to get
out and shake hands and kiss babies and
pretty perform it we didn't want to just
put the outbound and let it just sit
without people seeing it so what we did
in in the meantime was just kind of
trickle out
you know certain jams and kind of just
get them ready for tonight they ready
yeah the album is uh you know we got
killer we got a scottie atl we got chaos
cee-lo she's got ceelo on it yeah we got
ceelo on it yeah and uh you know it's
really special to us man it's both of
our vibes bro 14 tracks
no two songs sounded like it's just a
hell of a ride i mean from top to bottom
there's some on there for everybody like
every song is for everybody but there's
some on there for everybody right even
though we ain't been born yeah there's
something on there
you
foreign
really though